foreign
welcome back to CBS mornings where we've
got soccer on the mind because once
again it's win or go home for Team USA
at the World Cup in Qatar tomorrow
Saturday the Americans will take on the
Netherlands for a shot at the
quarterfinals first time these two
countries will face each other in a
World Cup match and the last time Team
USA made it to the quarterfinals round
was back in 2002 they lost to Germany in
that year Team USA Defender Walker
Zimmerman joins us now live from Doha
guitar Walker good morning
knockout round but really you guys have
been in The Knockout round already
because it was winner go home against
Iran you got the win how are you feeling
now does it change the feeling going
into a game knowing if you lose you're
done
you know you're right we we did have
that experience of having our first
knockout take place in the group stages
uh I thought we handled it really well
handled the pressure had a great game
obviously got the result and so uh we do
have a little bit of practice for these
knockout stages but we're excited
getting closer to kickoff here tomorrow
and uh the group is in in good spirits
and ready to go
Walker we're excited too and I'm saying
all the experts and I'm using experts in
finger quotes to say that Netherlands is
going to win this game you guys are the
underdog here and I always think it's
always good to be underestimated and
over deliver do you what is your
thinking going into that knowing so many
people say ah USA nope they're not going
to make it what's your feeling going
into that does that give you added
energy added boost
a hundred percent you know we've been
The Underdogs before uh U.S soccer is
used to that whole I think it's kind of
what has made our team so special is the
resiliency that we have uh that
competitive spirit that you know every
team before us has had and we feel like
we embody that really well with our
youth with our energy and with our
confidence so we aren't really worried
about what other people are saying we're
focused on the task at hand and that's
to go out there tomorrow and get a
result
so Walker your story is also energizing
uh you were told initially you didn't
make the roster then two other players
fell out and then you were sent to the
starting lineup uh talk to me about your
personal Journey here
yeah back in in World Cup qualifying
um a lot of ups and downs
um but started off in September not
playing not getting called in in October
was a replacement there and ended up
starting and doing well and earning my
spot in the starting 11 for the majority
of qualifiers so it's been a it's been a
fun ride and now to be able to represent
the US in a World Cup it really is a
dream come true and and all 26 guys are
are feeling good about having that
opportunity well Walker you really have
been making a difference uh there's that
great moment in the second half of the
game against Iran a tie would not have
been good enough for Team USA you're up
1-0 Iranians Iran's player gets around
the goalkeeper gets a shot on goal and
then you come out of seemingly nowhere
clearing the shot what did that moment
feel like yeah take us there yeah it was
it was great it's one of those moments
where you're just so into the moment
you're preparing for the worst anything
can happen and just the anticipation to
be in the right place at the right time
and make a play for the team and
ultimately seal the victory for us so
this special is
um you know a moment that I'll always
remember and it's something I can be
very proud of I like right place at the
right time but you got to have the
skills to do that Mr Zimmerman and you
certainly delivered on that can you tell
us how Christian is doing is he going to
play tomorrow do you guys even know that
yet
he's doing great he's in good spirits
um you know everything's day-to-day he's
doing all of his treatment and all of
his recovery but I think he's feeling
good and we'll be ready to go regardless
of what his status is
all your fans here in the US are very
excited we are ready to go we'll be
cheering you on and we appreciate you
giving us a few minutes of your time in
preparation ahead of the game thank you
Walker Zimmerman appreciate it good luck
good luck USA thank you very much